is being a youtuber your only profession
or do you secretly work for smartphone
companies with huge salary benefit
they're onto us hey what is up guys I'm
Kim PhD here happy new year welcome to
2017 and I'm about to head off to CES
2017 haven't miss one in a while I'm
probably editing this on the plane on
the way to CES so if you're the guy
sitting next to me on the plane
what's up this is totally normal stop
judging me this isn't weird so of course
I asked on Twitter if you guys had any
questions to start the new year tech
related or otherwise and had plenty so
these are those first one is are you
hiring so this is in relation to a tweet
I'd posted last year about whether or
not I would be hiring an assistant I
kind of mentioned that this is probably
this is most likely the year that I hire
someone to help with things around here
up until this point everything you've
seen on the channel has been made by me
but I think it's time to expand the
operation to be able to make not just
more stuff but better stuff to enable
things that just take me too long what's
the news with Apollo okay so the status
with Apollo if you didn't see that
updated tweets is that she's good
basically what happened was there was a
contaminant on the wiring in the
power-steering in the circuitry that was
not diagnosed by the first engineer but
the one they flew in fixed it so Tesla
is now really confident that they fixed
the issue I am really confident that
they fix the issue and there should be
no more problems with that car I've been
driving ever since and it's been
fantastic if it does have any more
problems obviously I bring it in and
that's probably the end of that don't
jinx it though do you plan on joining
your team krispies friends in LA at any
point I really like LA you know every
time I go there it's awesome
every time I go shoot with any of those
guys they teach me a lot I learn a lot
from being around them but I don't think
I'd like move to LA anytime soon there's
just too much good about this East Coast
thing this whole New York City being
right over there thing it's kind of just
a part of who I am now so yeah East
Coast bisko's why do your reviews seem
so biased um
because they are that's kind of inherent
to being a reviewer and doing reviews
it's funny though I do see that comment
a lot like this seems biased it seems
like you like this and don't like this
as much but that's kind of the point
that's why I'm a reviewer I'm not just a
spec sheet if you want
something completely unbiased you just
have to look at the list of the specs of
what hardware is in the device if I'm
doing a phone review but the whole point
of me talking about what I like and
don't like in a phone is so you get my
unique perspective and even if you don't
share my perspective even if you're not
biased in the same way that I am then
you can at least calibrate yourself to
watch my videos with that in mind so if
I like something for one reason and you
don't like it for that same reason then
the next time I like something for that
same reason you'll know that that's not
something you also like it's just kind
of works that way so my reviews and
pretty much every opinion I have is a
bias because I'm human
hopefully that helps would you ever
upload straight 8k video since YouTube
is not compatible with it I've thought
about it but probably not well actually
you said ever so I guess ever maybe a
long time from now that will happen but
right now there's almost no way to watch
in a que no one has an 8k screen even
now barely any people have 4k displays
and even of those people almost none of
them watch in 4k so I think I'll start
to upload an 8k the day that I can
actually have an 8k display and watch
and edit my own 8k videos in full 8k
it's probably going to be a while best
budget phone today 3t uh yeah I would
say the 3t the one plus 3t is my
favorite budget phone but then any time
you say the word budget got to be
careful because that's still a four
hundred something dollar phone a lot of
places and that's not budget for a lot
of people in fact here's another one of
the questions best sub $300 phone right
now that's a different question you got
to make sure you differentiate budget
phone from like soup like cheap phone
like really budget phone so I guess yeah
best 300 hour phone here try this for a
forfeit
iPhone 5se think about that yeah
Miguel asks pancakes or waffles come on
man really is that even a question
pancakes all debt TP over or under
really really is that even a question
over obviously all-day p100 dior prius
really really really its prius all-day
man that thing is a beast i like this
one are there any new pieces of camera
gear improving or changing how you're
making videos and it's not even new
pieces of camera gear but I've I keep
having this switch back and forth for
myself as youtuber maybe as a
cinematographer or another filmmaker you
can relate to this I keep switching back
and forth between zooms and primes I
really like at this moment
shooting with zooms a lot I'm using the
1835 right now I just like the
convenience of just being able to zoom
in and out whatever get my framing
exactly right whenever I'm running and
gunning I'm going outside and I don't
know exactly what shot I'm going to get
it's perfect for me to have a zoom but
whenever I start using primes again I
get really into primes for some reason
there's a couple problems I've played
with from Zeiss and from Canon that
really get me creative and challenge me
a little bit to get different unique
shots of things and you might not even
notice when you're watching the video
but it's very different so the shooting
style is different and it takes longer
obviously to switch lenses out and
reboot the camera every time I want to
change lenses for those shots but it
kind of makes it that much more
interesting so I go in like phases back
and forth between them I don't know if
anyone cares I just feel like that was a
fun question to answer I'll leave you
with this one favorite album of 2016
good question Sam and actually went back
and looked at a couple of albums I was
listening to for my most viewed playlist
on Spotify I'll link that that playlist
below but half of that stuff was not
even released this year I had like two
albums in mind and I looked at both of
them and they were both released in 2015
so it's kind of weird but what I'm going
to do is link one of my favorite artists
below mr. 20s while I'm going to link
his stuff below he's responsible not
only for a lot of the music like you
hear in my intro but like tons of great
music that I share all the time so I'm
gonna link that below and I'm going to
leave that as the outro track for this
video that's been it
hope you enjoy your 2017 so you let's
see yes if you're there thanks for
watching talk to you guys the next one
[Music]
I mean I've never do a lot that was
awarded in green the type that only oh
if it suited the need I would fight